so there I was what
the heavy case of amnesia in the middle
of nowhere the only clue to my past is
Harry's name and address
hat so I made my way to be apartment and
that's when I found you and your stapler
Colusa nation so you're talking Pikachu
with no memories is addicted to caffeine
I could stop whenever I want these are
just choices another round extra shot I
don't know maybe hair got in too deep
and mixed up the wrong crowd that kind
of thing
you can talk to humans I can talk to
Pokemon and if you want to find your
pops we're gonna need you to know I
don't need a Pokemon what about a
world-class detective Harry is still
alive case closed
but still open until I solve it
all right here it is Harry faked his own
death or somebody else faked carries
death
yeah Harry
think somebody else is dead that last
one doesn't work you know
[Music]
now obviously I've dealt what this pups
before so I'll just do it again
hey bud what are you doing I can't do
when people are watching
[Music]
that's a twist that's very twisty
no he's barely moving don't tell him
that
oh he's not a fight quick get in front
of him stop oh no he's going down hard
Tim should have worn a helmet
[Music]
[Applause]